Ich sage immer: "Ich bin
Edward Snowden für Deutschland."
Sind Sie das?
- Das sage ich so.
Ich bin für Deutschland
mindestens so gefährlich
wie Edward Snowden für Amerika.
So.
Snowden setzte sich
allerdings nach Russland ab,
Rainer Hoffmann tauchte vor
sechs Jahren in der Schweiz unter.
Snowden legte sich
mit den US-Geheimdiensten an,
Hoffmann mit der Solarindustrie.
Das ist ein ganz heftiges Ding.
So.
"Halbieren Sie Ihre Heizkosten."
Das ist aus dem Jahr 2005.
Da war das immer noch der Fall.
Damals warben sie
also richtig damit,
dass man mit einem Solarkollektor
seine Heizkosten halbieren könne.
Da steht auch nichts
im Kleingedruckten, was ...
Hier steht im Kleingedruckten:
"mögliches Einsparpotenzial."
Also, das haben Sie hier auch.
Dass bei
solch vollmundigen Versprechungen
Skepsis angebracht ist,
wurde Hoffmann erst klar,
als es schon zu spät war.
1996 entschied er sich,
in seinem Haus eine
Solarthermieanlage zu installieren,
womit diese Tragödie
ihren Anfang nahm.
Das ist das ursprüngliche Inserat.
Vom 19.1.1996.
Es enthält den Slogan:
"Lassen Sie sich nicht erzählen,
Solaranlagen für Brauchwasser
seien technisch nicht ausgereift
oder zu teuer."
"Wenn Sie Ihre Heizung neu planen -
dann planen Sie die Sonne mit ein."
"Es lohnt sich für Sie
und unsere Umwelt."
"60-70 % Ihres Warmwasserbedarfs
können Sie auch in Deutschland
mit einer Solaranlage decken."
"Wärme direkt ab Sonne."
Hoffmann ist nicht der Einzige,
der sich täuschen liess.
Hauptsächlich eigentlich
eine gewisse Kosteneinsparung
beim Gasverbrauch.
(Frau) Was würde das
bei Ihnen bedeuten?
Ich kann es noch nicht genau sagen.
Es hängt ja auch vom Ertrag ab.
Man sagt, im Durchschnitt könne man
ca. 70 % des Jahresbedarfs decken.
Das wird sich zeigen.
Je besser der Sommer wird, desto
besser ist die Energieausbeute.
Er kapierte den Schwindel nicht,
dass im Sommer nur ein Bruchteil des
Heizenergiebedarfs generiert wird,
den man mit einer Solaranlage
ersetzen könnte.
Und er weiss nicht,
dass sich die 70 % nicht auf
den gesamten Heizbedarf beziehen.
Sondern auf das Trinkwasser,
das nur rund 10 %
der Heizwärmekosten ausmacht.
Wir fahren nach Recklinghausen
in Nordrhein-Westfalen:
in Hoffmanns Heimat.
Hier leitete er
die Finanzbuchhaltung eines KMUs -
bis irgendwann
alles aus dem Ruder lief.
Seinen Kampf gegen die Solarindustrie
hat er teuer bezahlt:
Sein Haus gehört heute einem anderen.
Ach, der hat doch ...
Der hat ja noch ein Stück Solar
an diesem Ding befestigt,
was ich immer abgelehnt habe,
da es nicht die Südseite ist.
Das ist nur die Nordwestseite.
Das bringt ja gar nix.
Die hat er da auch noch hingemacht.
Sie haben ja alles verloren -
Ihre Arbeit und Ihr Haus.
Hat sich dieser Kampf gelohnt?
Für die Erkenntnis, wie schlecht
es um diesen Staat bestellt ist,
auf jeden Fall.
Dadurch erkannte ich,
wie politisch korrupt
das ganze System eigentlich ist -
gerade in Bezug
auf diese ganze Ökowirtschaft.
Das wurde mir dadurch bewusst.
Darum lohnte es sich, dass Ihre
ganze Existenz den Bach runterging?
Man darf doch nicht akzeptieren,
dass einige Leute
aus zwei und zwei fünf machen.
Wenn man das ...
Man ist im Grunde doch Mittäter,
wenn man das auf sich beruhen lässt.
Tragischer Höhepunkt war,
als die Polizei vor seinem Haus stand
und ihn verhaften wollte.
Das war dieses Haus.
(Hoffmann) Was wollen Sie
denn eigentlich hier?
(Polizistin) Ich muss
einen Haftbefehl vollstrecken.
(Polizist)
Das können wir so nicht machen.
Das sehen Sie doch!
- Machen Sie bitte die Tür auf!
Wenn Sie nicht verschwinden,
dann springe ich.
Kommen Sie mal da runter
und öffnen Sie uns die Tür.
Wehe, Sie hintergehen mich!
Nein, das tun wir nicht.
- Das haben alle hier mitgekriegt.
Ich komme jetzt runter.
- Ja.
So.
- Guten Abend, Herr Hoffmann.
Sie sehen, ich habe mich
ordentlich ausgewiesen.
Ich kann mich auch ausweisen.
- Schauen Sie hier.
Gut. - Darf ich Ihnen
meinen Ausweis auch zeigen?
Hallo, kommen Sie mal kurz?
* Geräusche einer Rangelei *
Ich tue Ihnen doch nichts!
Hilfe! Hilfe!
Hoffmann landete für eine Woche
in der geschlossenen Psychiatrie,
wo ihm ein Querulantenwahn
diagnostiziert wurde.
Oh, Mann!
Seine Rechtshändel fingen harmlos an.
Ah, da ist es.
Er weigerte sich,
die in seinen Augen mangelhafte
Solaranlage vollständig zu bezahlen,
und bestand darauf,
Opfer eines Betrugs geworden zu sein.
Das Gericht entschied gegen ihn.
"Eine Täuschung des Beklagten
liegt nicht vor."
"In seiner Werbeanzeige
hat der Kläger
nicht die Behauptung aufgestellt,
dass auch 60-70 %
des Wärmebedarfs der Heizung
durch Solarenergie
gedeckt werden können."
"Es entspricht nicht
der Verkehrsauffassung,
unter Warmwasserbedarf
auch den Wärmebedarf
für die Erwärmung des Heizungswassers
zu verstehen."
Vom Brauchwasser der Anzeige
ist im Urteil keine Rede.
Für Aussenstehende ein Detail,
für Hoffmann der entscheidende Punkt.
In einem anderen Urteil
spricht ein anderes Gericht
nämlich in Zusammenhang
mit dem Wasser im Heizungskreislauf
von Brauchwasser.
Darum habe er recht, findet Hoffmann,
aber die Justiz
wolle das partout nicht einsehen.
Obwohl es den Tatbestand
der Richterbeleidigung
insofern nicht gibt,
ist es ein Angriff
auf die Eitelkeit der Richter,
wenn man ihnen Fehler nachweist.
Dann ticken die aus.
Das ist jetzt ein guter O-Ton.
Das ist ein guter O-Ton.
Scheisse! Schnell weg hier!
Schnell weg
aus der Nähe des Amtsgerichts.
Es war die Ouvertüre
für eine ganze Reihe von Prozessen,
die Hoffmann fast alle verlor.
Er sei kein Querulant, sagt Hoffmann,
sondern vielmehr ein unnachgiebiger
Kämpfer für die Wahrheit,
der alles verloren hat.
Ja. Öffnen Sie mal!
- (Frau) Ja.
Immerhin:
Eine gute Freundin ist ihm geblieben.
Frau Stiller,
Sie sehen doch gut aus.
- Ach, Mensch!
Na?
- Das gibt's doch nicht!
Doch, das gibt's. Sie können es
auch mit Ihrer Nichte teilen.
Oh!
- Hier eine ganz schöne Sache.
Eine ganz schöne Sache.
- Wie kann ich das wiedergutmachen?
Eine ganz schöne, parktische Sache.
Passen Sie mal auf!
Jetzt bei diesem Wetter.
- Was ist das denn?
Ein Ventilator.
- Ah!
Ja, das tut gut.
* Er lacht. *
Der ist gut, was?
- Ja, der ist toll.
Praktisch für die Handtasche,
für unterwegs. - Ja.
Das hätte ich nicht gewusst.
- So was gibt's.
Ach ne, Herr Hoffmann ...
Die vom Amtsgericht standen
sofort am Fenster und guckten.
Die beiden
waren früher Arbeitskollegen
und blieben sich auch nach Hoffmanns
Flucht in die Schweiz verbunden.
Ich kann nur Gutes sagen.
Er hatte immer viel Geduld mit mir.
Er war ein guter Kollege. Das kann
ich nur immer wieder wiederholen.
Sie sehen ja:
Wir haben immer noch Kontakt.
Das tut so gut.
So sieht das aus, ja.
Und dann ist da natürlich
auch noch seine Mutter.
Wo bist du? Bist du zu Hause?
Ja, ab 14 Uhr bist du da?
Ja. Dann kommen wir um 14 Uhr.
Ja, aber sag das keinem!
So. Sachte.
So. Ja, du ... Sag es keinem!
Sag es keinem!
Hoffmann fürchtet, die Behörden
könnten auf ihn aufmerksam werden.
Trotzdem wagen wir einen Spaziergang
durch Recklinghausen.
Einen grossen Freundeskreis hatte
er nicht, als er noch hier lebte.
Und im Laufe seines Kampfes wendeten
sich immer mehr Menschen von ihm ab.
Galileo war auch ein Eigenbrötler.
Es waren alle
irgendwie Eigenbrötler.
Sehen Sie sich
etwas in dieser Tradition? - Ja.
Es ist ...
Wenn man sich intensiv
mit einer Materie beschäftigt,
steckt man halt
mehr drin als andere.
Dann hat man auch einen
ganz anderen Überblick. Und dann ...
Und vielleicht auch
einen gewissen Tunnelblick.
Nein, nein,
das lasse ich so nicht gelten.
Den Tunnelblick
lasse ich so nicht gelten.
Ich höre mir gerne
Kritik anderer an.
Bis jetzt
konnte ich alles widerlegen,
wenn jemand versuchte,
mir Gegenargumente zu liefern.
Das konnte ich ja alles widerlegen.
Ich konnte zeigen, dass das,
was behauptet wurde, nicht stimmte.
Dunkle Wolken.
Symbolisch.
Hoffmann wurde zum Verhängnis,
dass er verbreitete,
der Solaranbieter sei ein Betrüger -
was dieser mit Anzeigen quittierte.
Ausserdem stellte er
Beiträge von TV-Sendern
und Artikel aus Zeitschriften
ins Internet,
um deren falsche Berichterstattung
zu entlarven.
Diese Urheberrechtsverletzungen
wurden teuer.
Besuch bei einem,
der Hoffmanns öffentlichen Kampf
seinerzeit unterstützte.
Der freie Journalist
und Filmer Gerd Miethe.
Die Gerichte, die Richter etc.
versuchten mich ja
mehrfach zu psychiatriesieren.
Hm.
- Insgesamt sechsmal.
Es geschah dreimal am 20.4.
Okay.
- Kennen Sie den 20.4.?
Sagt Ihnen das was?
- Nicht wirklich.
Das war Hitlers Geburtstag.
- Okay.
Dann machen die das immer.
- Im Ernst?
Das ist eine verdeckte Mitteilung
an den Psychiater, dass ...
... der einen Knall hat?
- Ja.
Da brauchen sie gar nicht ...
Im Ernst? - Ja, ja.
Oder die sagen denen,
wie das Urteil der
Psychiatriesierung aussehen soll.
Hoffmann trat mehrmals
in Miethes Regionalradiosendung auf.
Bis auch Miethe Post
vom Anwalt des Solaranbieters bekam
und von weiteren Publikationen
absehen musste.
Leider, sagt Miethe,
denn er sei fasziniert
von Querdenkern wie Daniele Ganser,
KenFM und Rainer Hoffmann.
Mir fiel gleich auf, dass das jemand
ist, der weiss, wovon er spricht.
Ein genialer Kopf,
ein guter Rhetoriker,
jemand, der sich richtig tief
in Dinge einarbeiten kann
und darin regelrecht aufgeht.
Das fand ich total faszinierend.
Da will jemand etwas bewegen.
Nein, er ist überhaupt kein Spinner.
Im Gegenteil: Er ist einfach
zu schlau für die meisten.
(Originalton) Rainer Hoffmann hat
auf seiner Seite www.solarkritik.de
eine ganze Reihe
von Desinformationen
der TV-Sender dokumentiert.
In alternativen Medien
hat sich Hoffmann
eine kleine Fangemeinde aufgebaut.
Auch das öffentlich-rechtliche
Fernsehen berichtete über ihn,
seine Solaranlage
und seinen Kampf gegen
die Irreführung von Konsumenten.
(Originalton)
Aber klar ist gar nichts.
Hauptstreitpunkt: Was sind eigent-
lich 60 % des Warmwasserbedarfs?
Da gibt's z.B. die Begriffe
Brauchwasser, Trinkwasser,
Wärmebedarf, Warmwasserbedarf.
Diese Begriffe werden alle
uneinheitlich verwendet.
Aber alle meinen fast das Gleiche
und stellen fast das Gleiche dar.
Wenn dieser Schwindel -
ich nenne ihn mal so -
den Leuten klar werden und das
vehement in der Öffentlichkeit
und in den Medien diskutiert würde,
würde im Grunde der ganze Solarmarkt
zusammenbrechen.
(Orignalton) Die Zahl der Prozesse
zwischen Hoffmann
und der Justiz stieg.
Jede Zeile ein Verfahren.
Hoffmann gab keine Ruhe
und war bei seinen verbalen
Angriffen gegen die Behörden
sicherlich nicht immer gut beraten.
Die Behörden
wurden auf ihn aufmerksam:
Das Justizministerium
in Nordrhein-Westfalen
legte eine 198-seitige Akte
über Hoffmann an.
Deren Inhalt sei geheim zu halten,
befand ein Richter,
als Hoffmann Einsicht verlangte.
Hoffmann geht davon aus,
dass diese Geheimakte
unter Verschluss gehalten wird,
um zu vertuschen, was bei seinen
Prozessen alles schiefgelaufen sei.
Etwa, als auch
das Oberlandesgericht Hamm befand,
er sei nicht
Opfer eines Betruges geworden.
"Eine Irreführung
eines durchschnittlich informierten
und verständigen Adressaten"
sei in seinem Fall
nicht festzustellen.
Es geht um Prozessbetrug, um ...
Und letztlich
um Unterschlagung eines Gutachtens.
Zudem hat das Gericht
im Berufungsurteil
die falsche Werbeanzeige verwendet.
Das ist ganz massgeblich.
Es wurde nicht
die Werbeanzeige verwendet,
die im Jahr 1996
zum Kaufvertrag geführt hat.
Das ist die grosse Sauerei.
Das wurde alles
vom Justizministerium NRW
in Geheimaktenseiten
unter Verschluss gehalten.
Das Oberlandesgericht Hamm
bezog sich auf ein Verbraucherschutz-
urteil mit dieser Werbeanzeige -
und damit auf eine andere als die,
die zum Kauf von Hoffmanns
Solaranlage geführt hatte.
Zentraler Unterschied laut Hoffmann:
In der einen Anzeige steht
Brauchwasser, in der anderen nicht.
Als ich das mit den Werbeanzeigen
und den Datumswerten
beweisen konnte,
fiel das ganze Konstrukt,
das sie gegen mich erstellt hatten,
in sich zusammen.
Seitdem bin ich
bei denen Staatsfeind Nummer 1.
Wichser, ihr!
Die deutschen Behörden
sehen es ganz anders:
Alles sei stets korrekt abgelaufen.
Unbestritten ist:
2012 floh Hoffmann in die Schweiz,
weil ihm in Deutschland
die Zwangspsychiatriesierung drohte.
Er liess alles zurück -
auch seine geliebte Mutter.
Wieder einer umgestellt.
Meine Güte, du hier!
Jetzt sehe ich dich in natura.
Na, dann, rauf.
Oh, sie hat ja eine schöne Bude.
Das ist eine schöne Bude.
- Schöne Bude?
Ja, wenn die alte Bude ...
Deine schöne Bude.
Ja, geht ja noch.
Dort hatte ich
wohl eine schöne Bude.
Hier.
Tut das gut!
Der erste Besuch
nach sechs Jahren im Exil
wird zu einem Wechselbad der Gefühle.
Hast du eigentlich
noch Aktenordner im Keller?
Ja, in der Garage
sind all deine Aktenordner.
Die ganze Garage ist voll.
Hoffmann und seine Mutter
wohnten im selben Haus -
bis er floh
und das Haus zwangsversteigert wurde.
Da kaufte ich mir
eine Flasche Sekt und ein Messer.
Ich schnitt mir die Pulsadern auf
und legte mich auf dem Friedhof
auf unser Familiengrab,
wo meine Mutter
1944 beerdigt wurde -
das Grab existiert noch.
Sie wollten sterben?
- Ja, ich wollte sterben.
Ich habe mir
die Pulsadern aufgeschnitten.
Da muss nachts
wohl noch jemand rumgelaufen sein.
Der hörte mich jammern
und rief die Polizei,
weil es rechts und links
nichts gibt.
Sind Sie froh darüber,
dass Sie gerettet wurden?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
- Wieso nicht?
Nein, weil ... Was hatte ich denn?
Ich hatte ja nix.
Das war ... Scheiss doch
auf das Geld oder auf das Haus!
Ne.
- Es ist ärgerlich, aber ...
Irgendwo, also ...
- Nein, das will ich wiederhaben.
Nein, ich habe das heute ja gesehen.
* Hoffmann seufzt. *
Zusammen
mit einigen neuen Aktenordnern
geht es zurück in die Schweiz.
* Lachen *
Wobei die Aussichten
auch in der Schweiz trüb sind.
Er führt seinen Kampf
sozusagen aus dem Untergrund weiter:
gegen die deutsche Justiz
und die Solarindustrie.
Und neu auch gegen Klimaforscher,
die von einer gefährlichen
Klimaerwärmung reden.
Alles Quatsch, sagt Hoffmann -
und deckt Medien,
die aus seiner Sicht falsch
über den Klimawandel berichten,
mit Beschwerden ein,
so auch das SRF - bisher erfolglos.
"Die Psychiater
erklären mich für einen Spinner."
"Vielleicht
bin ich ja wirklich einer."
Gab es je einen Moment
der Selbstzweifel? - Nein, nie.
Nie. Ich weiss doch, was ich tue.
Hoffmann versteckt sich
seit sechs Jahren
vor der deutschen Justiz
und Psychiatrie.
Paul Bossert,
ein Freund aus besseren Zeiten
und ebenfalls ein Skeptiker
in Sachen Klimaforschung,
unterstützt ihn
mit Rat, Tat und Geld.
Hoffmann ist nirgendwo angemeldet,
hat keine Krankenkasse
und keine Arbeit.
Welche Perspektive sehen Sie für ihn?
- Ke... Also ...
Das kommt auf ihn an.
Das hat nichts mit mir zu tun.
Ich sehe keine Perspektive.
Ich sage nicht, dass alles gut wird
oder dass es nicht gut wird.
Das kann ich nicht.
Das ist seine Angelegenheit.
Er muss schauen,
wie er da wieder rauskommt.
Wie lange würden Sie
ihn noch unterstützen?
Ja, pff ...
Solange du lebst.
* Lachen *
Solange ich lebe, ja.
Ich hoffe, dass das
mal ein Ende hat, aber ...
Äh, pff ...
- Erst mal so.
Was wird denn aus ihm,
wenn Sie mal nicht mehr da sind?
Ja, das ist mir egal.
- Das kann dir egal sein.
Momentan
sei es eine Win-win-Situation,
sagen Bossert und Hoffmann.
Rainer muss um 16.45 Uhr weg?
- Genau.
Er hat Dienst.
* Rainer lacht. *
Na?
* Jammern *
Ja, ja. Alles gut, Brigitte?
Komm, jetzt kriegst du
die nächste Abkühlung.
Dienst, d.h.:
Hoffmann hilft Bossert
bei der Betreuung
seiner schwer dementen Frau Brigitte.
Schwups.
- Nein! - So ist es gut.
Sie ist
in einem Pflegeheim untergebracht.
Hoffmann holt sie täglich
für einen Spaziergang ab,
hilft ihr beim Essen
und macht Ausflüge mit ihr.
Es geht weiter.
Heute geht's in die Badi.
Na, Brigitte? Alles gut?
Klar ist:
für immer wird diese Win-win-
Situation nicht weiterbestehen,
Bossert ist inzwischen 80,
Hoffmann Mitte 50.
Der eine könnte irgendwann sterben,
der andere z.B. krank werden.
Spätestens dann würde es schwierig,
um nicht zu sagen: aussichtlos.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Natürlich hatte ich mein heutiges
Leben auch anders geplant,
aber ich sehe nicht nur die Schuld
bei mir bzw. kaum bei mir.
Ich habe eigentlich immer
ehrlich das gesagt,
was letztlich Fakt war.
Aber einige Leute
wollten nicht wahrhaben,
dass das die Fakten sind,
weil dadurch andere Leute
Probleme kriegen.
Man wollte ja nicht, dass diese
wichtigen Leute Probleme kriegen.
Darum vernichtete man
lieber mich, den "kleinen Mann".
So.
Dann nimmt diese Geschichte
eine unerwartete Wendung:
Hoffmann und Bossert
hatten einen heftigen Streit.
Bossert sagte, Hoffmann solle
abhauen, was dieser auch tat.
Bald aber bedauerte Bossert das Ganze
und meldete Hoffmann
bei der Polizei als vermisst.
Inzwischen
haben sich die Gemüter beruhigt.
Aber die Polizei
und das Migrationsamt
wurden auf Hoffmann aufmerksam.
Er müsse seiner Meldepflicht
nachkommen, wurde ihm beschieden.
Also tritt er
die Flucht nach vorne an.
Weil er definitiv gefährlich sei
für die Juristen in Deutschland,
beantragt er politisches Asyl
in der Schweiz.
Ich weiss zu viel
über die Justiz in Deutschland
und deren Machenschaften.
Insofern bin ich gefährlich
für die Justiz in Deutschland.
Das ist mein Problem.
Deswegen kann
und darf ich eigentlich
nicht nach Deutschland
zurückgeschickt werden,
weil das auch eine Bedrohung
für mein Leben bedeuten würde.
Man wird mich
wahrscheinlich nicht töten,
aber mit Psychopharmaka
mundtot machen wollen.
Das wird die Vorgehensweise sein.
Man darf gespannt sein, wie es
mit Rainer Hoffmann weitergeht.